How can you make sure you're getting enough
speaking practice outside the classroom?
This can be a real challenge for many English
learners.
Let’s take a look at a few ways you can
start practising your speaking.
Building your confidence is essential to improving
your speaking.
The easiest place to start is with everyday
situations.
If you are visiting an English-speaking country,
try following a routine like going to the
same coffee shop every morning to practise
there.
If you feel like a challenge, you could go
to the tourist information centre for directions
or ideas on what to do.
At home, you could focus on a new phrase or
idiom you’ve heard or read, and practise
using it.
Try repeating it to yourself first.
I know this sounds ridiculous, but when learning
a new language, we sometimes have to do extreme
things to help us.
Once you’re ready, you can have a go with
your classmates or friends.
Speaking of friends… always remember, you’re not alone!
Chances are there'll be others in your class
who may want to practise their speaking.
Set up a regular time with a friend or a group
of friends to talk in English.
If you're a keen cook, you could even host
an evening where you invite a few friends
to come over for dinner and talk in English.
Or maybe you're a keen reader.
Why not start a book group to discuss your
favourite books in English?
Are you worried that you’re not pronouncing
words properly and this is keeping you from
practising your spoken English?
Most dictionary websites and apps will have
an audio of the word so you can check the
pronunciation.
Depending on the app or website you're using,
the accent will be a little bit different.
If you are looking for a specific accent,
make sure to include it in your search.
Practising pronunciation will build your confidence,
which will in turn improve your fluency.